this is what I would say about your
fashion the one thing I would say here
we go I I'm not a fashionable person but
I don't think when I walk into a crowd
people notice what I'm wearing but when
you notice I know but that's you you
notice everything you notice everything
about everybody because you need to make
sure that you're better than them but
but throw it away for a second yeah you
do you your fashion choices are kind of
bold and do stand out he asks for all
the attention no no seeking attention
with these outfits I honestly don't feel
that way I don't know if this is
interesting to people this conversation
my fashion by the way but I think what's
bold is that I actually try to comb my
hair and iron my clothes and around this
office yeah everyone looks like a slob
and so I guess it does stand out as bold
but to me it's just normal human beings
trying to look presentable listen a lot
of people compliment me on the hat you
can Goof on it it does take balls to
wear a hat like that I cannot walk 10
feet in New York City without someone
going that's a cool ass hat man and that
I know it is you're realize it's when
sometimes when people see the Hat
they're they're taken aback by it right
and they don't like it but they just go
up here because no just in general they
go oh cool hat because they don't know
what to say but they noticed the Hat
well I think the hat looks good I think
the hat is very sharp the hat is what
wasn't what was wrong with your outfit
from the other day it was everything
else the tie the belt the uh overly
racist boots Gary
your cowboy boots aren't even regular
cowboy boots they're like aggressive
they're they're extra cowboy boots like
they they're real they're longer than
most Cowboys boots and they kind of
they're as long as my phone on the end
they're very pointy and on the end they
kind of tip up they curl up nice toe